crowd said you could resist a good
crisis
you'll bark gone you don't belong here
and miss the return of Barry Allen
happy injustice to week everybody this
is going to be my review of the game I
also included both endings at the end of
the video just because this is dropping
everywhere I'm going to do a new round
of the injustice to giveaway it's for a
copy of the game all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video and just a reminder if
you're new to the channel giveaway
winners are usually announced at the end
of videos so the biggest thing about
this game you've probably heard a lot
about the extra new features that they
added into it it's way bigger than the
last game everything looks better
everything plays better but they've also
added so many new features that's mostly
the gear system and multiverse mode so
multiverse mode I'll talk about in a
second because story mode is the thing
that everybody starts with most of the
time first the story is way bigger than
last time if you played the last game a
lot though a lot of the choices will
feel familiar so if you're like a huge
injustice to fan it is a lot of fun but
some of the really big twists aren't as
big as you think they would be but it is
a lot of fun like the last two endings
which I'll talk about when I get to
spoilers at the end but the amazing
thing is that I felt like Harley Quinn
from injustice 2 actually was a better
version of the character than she was in
Suicide Squad
so the actual story of story mode
campaign is just as good as any DC movie
as we've gotten so far
now that might change soon because all
the reactions are coming in from Wonder
Woman all the critics really love it way
more than any of the movies that have
come before so we'll see about that
but you're basically getting a giant DC
movie set in the multiverse so they play
with that in really fun ways but all the
characters work great it's always
awesome to hear Kevin Conroy come back
to do the voice of Batman he's still one
of my most favorite Batman's of all time
it is a bummer that a lot of the TV
actors can't complain roles like a lot
of people want to Grant Gustin to do the
voice of the flash but the gameplay is
relatively simple like if you're just a
button masher you'll still have a lot of
fun like if you really want to play
through story mode super fast the first
time you can just set the game on easy
but if you're super hardcore you can
crank the difficulty up you get more
rewards you can gear your character out
faster and you can start destroying
people in PvP that much faster and
that's a big thing to some characters
like Superman Darkseid they have better
specials that are more powerful but if
you go up against another player that
just has wave
better gear then you're at a serious
disadvantage but you can use the
different story mode multiverse modes
different parts of the game to gear your
character up so if you just like playing
by yourself you can still gear your
character up and I know the big question
too is if you have to buy the premium
versions of the game to get all the
extra skins and the characters like I
want reverse-flash does that mean that I
have to pay for the hundred dollar
version of the game no it does not
everything that you get with those
premium versions of the game you can get
through natural gameplay it just takes
you a little bit longer to unlock those
things but I will say combos and special
moves are your best friend the faster
you can learn how to unlock like a seven
hit combo the faster you will places a
game you can destroy most of story mode
pretty much everything at least on
medium difficulty as long as you can
unlock a few combos but it's all just a
matter of finding a character whose
combos you really like and work well
against the characters you're going up
against because as you level up the
types of characters that you fight get a
little more difficult so if you're
fighting someone like Bane who's a
grappler you don't want to use a
character to fight him that fights up
close because once it gets his hands on
you it is over so you might want someone
like green arrow with more ranged
attacks to go up against him but I
haven't seen too many people complaining
about the gear I think it's a cool new
addition but it is a bit of a hassle to
try and go around and upgrade your gear
you get low level gear that seems really
cool but your character levels up really
fast your gear does not level up with
you you have to level it up with
transform tokens which are a [ __ ] to
get or you just win better gear from the
matches most of you will probably blow
through story mode pretty quickly I made
it through broad like which is stage 3
stage 4 pretty fast after that it gets a
little bit harder so just make sure you
learn those special moves learn those
combos but the biggest complaint that
I've seen so far and it's totally fair
is that your choices during story mode
don't really influence the game that
much like you get to choose between one
or two characters like you have black
canary in green arrow you can use one of
them to fight during the Grod matches
but it doesn't really change the outcome
once you win the match now when you get
to the end that's different there are
two different endings they're sort of
like the darkest timeline ending and
then
the more rational ending and even though
it is a fun way to drive the characters
forward the two different endings will
feel very familiar to the first game but
I'll play them here then give my final
words on the game so here we go
[Music]
Oh
you're okay I thought it was too late
but I can feel the heartbeat of Atlantis
brainiacs work is undone not all odd I
couldn't save everyone some cities are
still trapped in the collection others
were lost white from the ships memory
metropolis coast city but we can still
save them right Carol my family I'm
sorry how first Krypton now earth no
other world should suffer this
Clark no
even if I agreed that he should die you
can't we need him alive to save the rest
of our cities no we don't with more time
cyborgs help the ship will obey me I
wish we were family Cara
[Music]
I hope someday you see that
are you alright no this symbol should
give people hope he made them spirit
that symbols meaning is up to the person
who wears it when Clark and I founded
the Justice League we didn't govern
people we protected them plain and
simple maybe the world could use a team
like that again welcome to the circle of
trust
[Music]
you bonded with Brainiac [ __ ] Brainiac
is dead
the remaining cities have been restored
and just like I told you
Earth is it peace under your heel I wish
you'd come around Cara I'm building a
new army to protect the earth there are
billions of warriors trapped in
brainiacs collection Kryptonians daksa -
zarnian I'll have a legion whose power
rivals the combined Lantern cores and I
want you to lead it with me you'll
either make the right choice or I'll
make it for you
what's it going to be so those are
pretty crazy endings but it's a lot like
the first game Superman wins things get
crazier Batman wins things are still a
little bit crazy but not quite as bad
but I think the real value in the game
is in the replay in the way that they're
adding new fresh content on a regular
basis so the multiverse mode is really
the key to that so just a reminder you
don't have to buy the most expensive
version of the game you can still get
all the cool stuff through natural
gameplay with the cheapest version of
the game what's going to happen next is
I'm working on a flash Batman Button
crossover video they've been asked a
whole bunch of stuff about the Marvel
movies that are coming up so I'll try to
get those videos out as fast as possible
and we have some flash finale to talk
about but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Jamie 23:05 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post a DC video so you can
click here for brand new flash and you
can click here to rewatch that new black
lightening trailer thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight
you